if I learned one lesson from my time
with the CIA it is this everybody
believes they're the good guy I was an
officer with the CIA clandestine service
and worked undercover on
counterterrorism and intelligence all
around the world for almost ten years
the conversation that's going on in the
United States right now about Isis and
about the United States overseas is more
oversimplified than ever ask most
Americans whether Isis poses an
existential threat to this country and
they'll say yes that's where the
conversation stops if you're walking
down the street in Iraq or Syria and ask
anybody why America dropped bombs you
get they were waging war on Islam and
you walk in America and you ask why are
we attacked on 9/11 and you get they
hate us because we're free those are
stories manufactured by a really small
number of people on both sides who amass
a great deal of power and wealth by
convincing the rest of us to keep
killing each other I think the question
we need to be asking as Americans
examining our foreign policy is whether
or not we're pouring kerosene on a
candle the only real way to disarm your
enemy is to listen to him if you hear
them out if you're brave enough to
really listen to their story you can see
that more often than not you might have
made some of the same choices if you'd
lived their life instead of yours and
al-qaeda fighter made a point once
during a debriefing he said all these
movies that America makes like
Independence Day and Hunger Games and
Star Wars they're all about a small
scrappy band of rebels who will do
anything in their power with the limited
resources available to them to expel an
outside technologically advanced invader
and what you don't realize he said is it
to us to the rest of the world you are
the Empire and
we are Luke and Han you are the aliens
and we're Will Smith but the truth is
when you talk to the people who are
really fighting on the ground on both
sides and ask them why they're there
they answer with hopes for their
children specific policies that they
think are cruel or unfair and while it
may be easier to dismiss your enemy as
evil hearing them out on policy concerns
is actually an amazing thing because as
long as your enemy is a subhuman
psychopath that's going to attack you no
matter what you do this never ends but
if your enemy is a policy however
complicated that we can work with
you